LT anina no tratamento do TDH infantil
pode ajudar menina de 7 anos muito
agitada bim eu gosto muito do LT anina é
o aminoácido natural encontrado no chá
verde que é uma grande arma aí para
acalmar o cérebro sem deixar a pessoa
sedada e é sim uma opção muito
interessante no manejo do transtorno de
Déficit de Atenção e hiperatividade em
crianças isso obviamente vai incluir
meninas nessa faixa de idade de 7 anos
de idade então nós conhecemos as
propriedades da L teanina ela tem
propriedades calmantes ela tem
propriedades de aumentar a concentração
foco isso pode ajudar bastante a reduzir
a ansiedade e hiperatividade então
estudos mostram que a l teanina pode
promover um estado de relaxamento em
atensão melhorando a concentração e a
calma em crianças com TDH isso ocorre
porque el teanina vai aumentar os níveis
de gaba no cérebro vai influenciar a
atividade cerebral aumenta a produção de
outros neurotransmissores fora o Gaba
meu caso da dopamina e serotonina que
são importantes pra regulação do m e da
atenção só que não é só a lanina também
é muito importante a bordar TDH com uma
estratégia mais abrangente que inclui
mudança estilo de vida isso envolve uma
dieta equilibrada rque nutrientes
cortando o açúcar cortando processados
industrializados tirando os corantes
artificiais a prática de atividade
física também muito importante as
crianças hoje não saem de casa elas não
se exercitam então é muito importante
fazer atividade física para ajudar a
controlar a hiperatividade e melhorar a
concentração e outras abordagens
naturais fora a el teanina pode ser uso
do ômega-3 é muito interessante como
antiinflamatório cerebral e são
essenciais pro desenvolvimento dos
neurônios e a prática de técnicas de
relaxamento com meditação yoga que vai
ajudar a gerenciar o estresse e
ansiedade criança sim pode fazer yoga e
pode fazer meditação